quiet quitting is a really bad idea
you're ready to quiet quit when you just
quiet started last week how fast do you
think success comes we said hard work
pays off we never said it pays off in 30
seconds life is not an ATM you can't
just press a button and the cash comes
out it takes longer a lot longer to get
the payout um excuse me but here's the
good news if you're a younger person and
you're just starting out in your career
the deck has been cleared okay many of
your peers are are settling for
mediocrity already they haven't even
tried yet and they've decided there's no
point in trying they totaled their cars
on the first speed bump they came across
they ran into a mild Breeze and were
knocked on their asses and have no
interest in getting up this is an
opportunity for you if you're not one of
those people as long as you have
slightly more fortitude and a slightly
better work ethic than all those other
losers you have an opportunity you only
need to be slightly more useful than a
slug to set yourself apart and then
imagine if you went above and beyond
even that imagine if you really tried
the stage is set for you to succeed